or la parole est à monsieur marc
laffineur merci monsieur le président
monsieur mise de l'intérieur vous savez
un partout dans les départements on voit
bien la sécurité monte actuellement et
c'est bien le sentiment qu'on l'ait
france mais ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de l'environnement
madame la ministre il ya une crise
profonde chez les 1 million 200 mille
chasseurs officiellement créée le 1er
janvier 2017 la chance française pour la
biodiversité a tenu son premier conseil
d'administration le 19 janvier on peut
s'étonner que parmi la quarantaine
l'administrateur nommé par votre
ministère
aucun représentant de la chasse
française ne soit membre de cette
instance où siègent par exemple des
représentants de la pêche on peut
également s'étonner de la place
considérable fait dans l' agence au
rassemblement des opposants à la chasse
l'ancien président du rassemblement des
opposants à la chasse devient ainsi
président d'honneur de l' agence pour la
biodiversité
un autre représentant du rock siège
désormais au sein du conseil
d'administration de l'aef b et enfin
l'ancien directeur du rassemblement des
opposants à chasser devenu le pr le
directeur général de l'agencé pour la
biodiversité
le message envoyé au monde de la chasse
est considéré comme une provocation dans
ce contexte remarqué nous apprenons que
l'administration du ministère de
l'environnement s'emploie à créer à
marche forcée des services communs à l'
agence française pour la biodiversité et
à l'office national de la chasse ce qui
est perçu comme une intégration masqué
de l'office dans l' agence cela a été
dénoncé par conseil d'administration de
l'office national de la chasse
madame la ministre est envoyé et lequel
a envoyé d'ailleurs une motion président
de la république madame rémy nice
qu'en est il de l'engagement du
président de la république de préserver
l'indépendance et l'autonomie de
l'office national de la chasse
merci la parole est à madame ségolène
il ya le ministre de l'environnement
président monsieur le député mesdames et
messieurs débuté d'abord merci d'avoir
souligné l'importance de la création de
l' agence française de la biodiversité
qui a été je le rappelle quand même voté
à l'unanimité non seulement l'assemblée
nationale mais au sénat donc vous l'avez
voter et je vous en remercie monsieur
laffineur vous prétendez que les
chasseurs ne sont pas membres de l'
agence française de la biodiversité mais
les chasseurs ont refusé d'entrer dans
l' agence française de la biodiversité
et vous savez combien au cours du débat
parlementaire j'ai insisté pour qu'il
rentre dans cette agence nous avons
besoin de leurs compétences de leur
expertise
ils connaissent parfaitement bien la
nature et les espèces
il participe j'ai l'occasion de
travailler avec eux sur les
replantations en particulier et par
conséquent je suis la première à
regretter que les chasseurs ne soit pas
membre de l' agence française de la
biodiversité il serait ainsi au conseil
d'administration mais si je vous entends
bien et si vous en faites la demande
nous pouvons très rapidement voté une
délibération complémentaires qui
permettra aux chasseurs de rentrer dans
l' agence française de la biodiversité
et j'en serai la première satisfaites
merci la part